ah welcome to this video I'm playing
swap again I am Miller from Germany so
can we do something else he always play
so maybe I can let's play the triangle
with this don't even know but do you
remember how we played in earlier games
how does he do that damn does he take no
not sure if we even discuss this that
often yeah this is a voice played with a
for I don't know but I had a game
recently yeah it was quite successful
with this move nobody else plays it like
that but boys felt its kind of logical
to take this pawn so let's see what he's
doing probably just a six I always felt
that black m is not quite equal here as
the Queen side is always somewhat
weakened
okay yep 9 10 PT 2 nite often aims for
you three in this position yeah t I
always went couldn't be three do I need
to though sometimes there is the c5 d5
motif that's that's really cute is this
one of them it's playable c5 d5 he takes
I'll take be five
yeah that's it seems playable what I
don't really know is what told me I
should go home I played the bishop and
then c5 d5 he takes it a Bab bishop it's
two moves with the bishop that's kind of
not ideal maybe just play this one I
know it doesn't really fit together with
night BTW too but at least I'm
preventing c-54 the mood probably this
is the typical center they say i
prevented c5 then whoosh he goes anyway
and i don't think he can though no not
in this position so I'm just going to a
complete development here castles route
FC one and ask him how is going to play
c5
the night is still probably better on t2
then it is on c3 on c3 they're always
would be some kind of before yeah before
happening and I wanted to say that
before now it is less attractive because
of the 94 possibility even though
certainly you can think of about the
move anyway so c5 how am I going to play
yeah a5 comes into consideration trying
to go for night see for the right moment
but take on f6 i think i'm going to take
them the bishop is not really relevant
for the fight around be for NC 5 and in
this particular movie has to take with
the night which is not bad rook see one
just look see one here
not really sure I should go in five him
night c4s also move on t1 yeah this is
kind of position some they are
strategically complicated you have to
you don't have to but it is really nice
to have some time to figure out the
differences between the various moves
and so he does that anyway now even
though I have the discovery seem so it
doesn't mind 94 or other night
discoveries yeah i think i'm happy with
94 didn't really think about this move
so much probably a mistake
well no I didn't think about that at all
that it's bad mmm should see for maybe
ya know I then he takes you four stupid
94 my hospital was badly played coming
from a comfortable position to this one
I know so I don't feel so well against a
mess course is positive but I do i often
get some questionable or downright bad
positions
time morning shift c4 that's okay aight
i guess really like to trade this trader
the bishop there hmm
what kind of a bad game in him down to
30 seconds very stupid this is not a
very very good move anyway I couldn't go
e 4
yeah unfortunately you can just do that
threatening you fall down can I somehow
hold this just about
empty eight maybe
16 seconds it's probably lost anyway and
with 16 seconds it's impossible even
though he is very slow usually check
check I I didn't see that one yeah I
really hate those kind of games like
resides you just have the better
position out of the opening black should
usually just suffer for a long time and
then you stumble into the specialty 5
business is just right not working at
all 95 and white is basically winning ah
come on hmm didn't think about that move
yeah okay this is this is some very easy
win actually yeah I'm Chad getting a six
ah yeah I was really thinking okay ships
e5 should look somewhere I be should be
five should work somehow it does it
doesn't that didn't think about 95 why I
loved if I had not even had I didn't
have it on the raid I at all yes I the
bad thing is that the alternative is
continuous yeah I only have this clearly
better position on the clear the worst
position there's nothing in between
check after 40 seconds that's terrible
or William yeah i know i'm just-just in
bad shape let's just a variety variety
of bad positions that you have
impossible to save and teach black as
black is just in time yeah check check
Joe that's very easy so I do it all came
down to one position we're here you made
this mistake with Bishop g5 Queenie 7 I
thought that this should be an oops I'm
slightly better for white due to the
before porn but the engine does not
agree it just says equal maybe it's
possible if anything it was clear that
if I have something it couldn't be much
but yeah this is one supposed to work
and just take and and he's in bad shape
anyway thanks for watching